u.s troops are among the last to leave
among international forces and while
huge numbers of afghans have been flown
out many who want to leave are stranded
this and the looming humanitarian crisis
have set off a flurry of diplomatic
moves the u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken will hold a virtual meeting with
several allies including qatar and
turkey
while france and the uk will urge the
u.n security council to protect
civilians and ensure a safe passage for
those who want to escape
we have three correspondents covering
all these developments in afghanistan
kristen salumi is live at the united
nations to give us more details on
what's being discussed there for the
latest on the ground in kabul we have
rob mcbride standing by but first let's
take you to alan fisher he's at the
white house
to address that pentagon briefing so
very clear there the the message which
the pentagon is trying to emphasize is
that they've done
a huge job when it comes to evacuations
right alan
that's right and john kirby is saying
look no one could have expected the
afghan government to collapse quite so
quickly
there were people suggesting that that
might happen so there will be questions
after this about whether or not there
was a huge intelligence failure as there
was 20 years ago when osama bin laden
coordinated the attacks in the united
states on 9 11 which precipitated the us
going into afghanistan in the first
place
what was interesting of the five rockets
that were launched at the airport
overnight only one landed one was
intercepted by the rocket system three
landed outside the airport but this talk
about how they are able to continue to
target people even after the united
states uh pulls out is what they've
talked about for a long time this over
the horizon security capability to be
able to still neutralize threats that
they see
and i know from speaking to people over
the last few hours that the americans
really want this operation to be done
they want to get to the deadline they
want all the american troops out every
american who wants to leave they want
them out they want to remove as many
afghans as they possibly can and do it
without loss of life because as we've
seen
13 lives lost at the end of last week
and then a number of civilians killed
as the pentagon says it targeted what
was potentially a car bomb in kabul on
sunday they really just want to wake up
on wednesday or thursday morning and
have the headache of processing all
these people rather than have the
headache of ending
america's presence in afghanistan after
20 years and kind of related to that you
and i were chatting before the show
about the whole issue of counter
terrorism operations security
cooperation that came up in the press
briefing didn't it about
what sort of as the americans are
calling it over the horizon
counter-terrorism capabilities will be
maintained and how much coordination
will there be with the taliban
what is clear is that at the moment the
real politic dictates that the taliban's
in charge of afghanistan they're in
charge of kabul therefore the united
states has to work closely with them to
make sure that this operation continues
as smoothly as possible what happens in
the future well we have already heard
from the taliban who condemned the
attack uh that targeted
the so-called spotter the senior isil
figure that was killed in a drone attack
and then they also condemned the attack
on sunday which we believe may have
killed innocent civilians what is clear
from speaking to some security people i
know is that they don't think there will
be sharing of intelligence with the
taliban they say it's a complicated
situation but they believe that there is
too much overlap between isil k and the
taliban even though the two groups are
meant to be in opposition there are
still
links between the two groups and
therefore the united states are not
isn't going to flag anything up before
it carries out an operation if they
think in john kirby's words
that there is a a threat to the united
states or to americans emanating from
afghanistan then they will act
they said that although the us and the
the war in afghanistan
that's come to an end what will not end
is this commitment to continue to
protect americans so it will be
complicated
excuse me there may be discussions on a
diplomatic level between the taliban
and the united states but the idea of
them sharing intelligence uh according
to the people i've been speaking to
seems far-fetched unless
there is a common goal unless there is
something that the taliban
need dealt with or have highlighted and
the united states believes it's also in
its interest to take some action on that
front then there may be some joint
action but from the people i've been
speaking to say it's far too complicated
to consider sharing any intelligence
with the taliban all right good stuff
there from alan fisher let's thank him
for that let's head over now to rob
mcbride he joins us live from kabul and
of course we had those latest rocket
attacks
uh towards kabul airport what does the
situation on the ground look like or the
aftermath of those attacks look like
i think it is quite troubling for the
americans probably more in psychological
terms as they're now into this end game
of this evacuation exercise because
there seems to be little indication of
actual harm or damage but the u.s had
warned specifically about a rocket
attack as one of the continuing threats
from this islamic state affiliate it
seems to be prepared for that it
deployed as we just heard in
confirmation there with more details
from the pentagon this anti-rocket
system that it has it said it was
successful intercepting uh several of
the rockets as they came in as saying
that just one of those rockets fell
harmlessly it says uh in a an open piece
of land the uh
the um islamic state group has claimed
responsibility they say a total of six
katushka style rockets were fired
presumably from a vehicle which was seen
to be on fire after this uh this attack
um but the evacuation exercise continues
this monday evening all throughout the
afternoon and into now the hours of
darkness here we have been watching uh
from the end of the runway as these big
c-17 transport planes have been
lumbering off into the sky and as they
do of course we are counting down the
hours now until the end of this exercise
the military contingent there the
american military contingent is starting
to reduce its footprint at ever smaller
base within the airport giving up
positions to the taliban in preparation
for the
very final flight as we heard from the
pentagon there they they know exactly
when that is going to be but they are
going giving no indication of that it is
as we know sometime between now and this
deadline of tuesday midnight here local
time what an important development is
aid now being flown into the country
that is an important development we've
heard about uh this monday the
confirmation of this aid flight
specifically by the world health
organization uh a flight into mazari
sharif in the north of the country now
in practical terms this is very
important for the who they said last
week that they were down to just 10 days
of supplies for the whole of afghanistan
it made what is a worsening humanitarian
crisis it has says that there were
supplies in dubai it wanted to get into
the country and it seems to have found a
way which does open the wider potential
for air routes into afghanistan bizarre
sharif is a big important city in the
north it has a big important airport
before the collapse of the government
there are international flights there so
this is a confirmation that they have
restored air traffic control which does
seem to pave the way or show the way
forward for kabul here because of course
once the us departs they take with them
air traffic control and the taliban will
have the uh the unenviable job of not
only restoring airport but restoring
that air traffic control so it does
offer a way forward which everybody here
it seems wants to see the government the
aid organizations and most importantly
of course the population because that
would then
mean the return eventually of commercial
flights all right thanks so much rob
mcbride let's take this now to kristen
salumi she's joining us from the united
nations have been discussions there
about afghanistan where does security
council stand on getting a resolution
out
well we know that the united kingdom and
france have been pushing a resolution
that we expect some action on later in
the day
that essentially calls for the continued
safe passage of civilians and aid
agencies in and out of kabul
worth noting that the taliban has
said that civilians will be able to come
and go as they please
this essentially puts it in writing lets
the taliban know that the international
community plans to hold them to that
commitment by enshrining it in
international law the resolution also i
think attempts to put the focus back on
the humanitarian situation in the
country with so much attention on people
trying to leave afghanistan u.n
officials have been warning that the
situation on the ground is increasingly
dire there was concern about medical
supplies running out
earlier today who the world health
organization got its first flight into
the country
since the taliban takeover bringing much
needed medical supplies and health
related supplies into the country some
12 and a half metric tons that are uh
expected to be delivered to
29 different provinces and health
centers but that flight had to land in
uh mazzar e sharif it could not land in
kabul because of the terrible security
situation there
so un officials are
warning that there are some three and a
half million
displaced people inside afghanistan
about a half a million of those
happening in the last year and and
they're warning that the situation on
the ground is just going to get worse
after the
united states withdrawal so this
resolution we do expect to be voted on
in the coming hours and it's
the hope there uh that the taliban will
see that the world is watching and that
this will uh make a difference going
forward
all right thanks so much kristen salumi